you got to hear this about will what he
had to get a colonoscopy and you know
how you do prep for a colonoscopy
yes he drink all that stuff and so in
the middle of the night he just [ __ ]
the entire like just [ __ ] all over his
bed and he goes well imagine he
lives with a woman he's got a wife and
he woke his wife up to tell her that he
[ __ ] the bed like he had like hey here's
some big news
you married a baby
[Laughter]
but dude when you but how do you sleep
through that experience don't you wake
up and go
like when i have to pee i don't pee in
my bed i just go oh [ __ ] i gotta get up
and go pee
i mean it was pretty i was pretty far
along in the prep
so you know it was basically leaking out
of me at that point
but um i fell asleep i don't know
and what did you do after you [ __ ] the
bed like how much [ __ ] was in your bed
well you know at that point it's
basically water it's not like a turd or
anything like that
so i woke up i'm like oh my god i felt
my ass and it was all wet i'm like oh no
this happened so then of course i had to
wake up my wife real quick
like we gotta change the sheets put down
towels
so yeah we pulled the sheets off and
unfortunately a little bit
got to the mattress and didn't you wet
your bed
a couple of months ago yeah that one i
got no excuse for i don't know what the
hell happened there
was something medically wrong with you i
mean seriously
i had an accident listen the prep
ended at midnight so then i had like six
or seven hours to kill
i don't know i just fell asleep and it
came out of me yeah
why did your prep end at midnight like
why wouldn't you start i don't know that
was annoying too
like what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
i'm you know i got to sleep for a few
hours
i think you just [ __ ] the bed i just
think you were too lazy to get up
it wasn't a choice yeah i kind of think
it is
are you [ __ ] right now not right now
right now i feel good so how
how are you controlling it how are you
controlling [ __ ] right now
like why are you [ __ ] in your pants
we'll see big shot if this happens to
you one day
it has enough they'll make mistakes make
a mistake that's not a mistake that's a
catastrophe